[Music]
our final sound check Turkish singer
ilka akaya and her band are getting
ready to perform
but will the concert in the southern
Turkish city of Adana really take place
in recent months many of akaya's
performances have been canceled often at
short notice
[Music]
I read on Twitter the night before our
concert in mezin that it was canceled
it's pretty rough every time I mean the
venues are rented the equipment is on
its way the musicians are booked and
then all of a sudden it's forbidden due
to some regulation
more concerts and festivals have been
banned in Turkey this year than ever
before
just the list of canceled music
festivals alone is long
in past years many were attended by tens
of thousands of people the bands are
usually justified by protecting public
order
but ilka akaya is suspicious
they try to impose a certain way of life
on us
it's often female singers who are
affected by the prohibitions
because these people think women should
stay at home
musicians who stand up for fair and
Freer conditions are also affected it's
taken as criticism of the government and
this is how they're silenced
pop singer gulshan is a thorn in the
side of the ruling religious
conservatives under Turkish president
erdogan for another reason
pro-government media Outlets claim her
outfits violate the values of the people
she's currently being tried in court for
allegedly making disparaging remarks of
a Islamic religious schools
the islamist party Huda par welcomes the
state's Crackdown for them it's a
question of morality
these concerts familiarize people with
such immoralities
there is not only a serious economic
crisis in the country at the moment
there is also a crisis of morality and
decency
and this moral crisis is only
exacerbated by such concerts which are
incompatible with our faith
for some conservatives in Turkey Rock
and pop music such as ilka achillas is
as dangerous as drugs
but concert goers in Adana say these are
just excuses
some fear that turkey is becoming more
and more religious
with the bands they want to prevent this
part of society and culture from growing
we've attended countless concerts in our
lives and enjoyed ourselves
of course the fact that our children
might not have these same experiences
worries us
this particular concert does take place
freedom is a common theme in ilka
akaya's music the audience cheers her on
[Music]
but Rock and pop music is increasingly
been portrayed as immoral
critical observers suspect this is
intended to satisfy conservative voters
before next year's elections
islamist parties like Huda par recognize
the opportunity
we shouldn't talk about these bands all
the time
instead we should talk about the
alternatives for young people we also
organize concerts Sports and cultural
events ones that actually connect young
people to their own values and
traditions
tour through this Turkish Province came
to an end that evening
the following concert was canceled this
time by the organizers possibly due to
pressure from the authorities
[Applause]
it's not just me who's being slowly
deprived of a livelihood it's my 10
musicians collaborators and their
families too
this policy is simply unlawful and
unjust
and many fellow artists in Turkey will
continue making music despite the threat
of being silenced